John when did you sign on to this
project how long you've been working on
it oh about three years ago three years
ago three years ago Justin had been on
before me they were developing the story
with the studio there was a they were
working on a treatment but the idea of
doing this live-action Disney was had
had some success with other live-action
adaptations so they came to me it was
already a twinkle in their eye and and
then the the big thing that was
interesting to me about it because I
enjoyed the the 67 film right and I
didn't understand what I would really do
here and then Alan horn from Disney was
talking about films like Life of Pi and
Avatar and that got me excited because
we were not just gonna create digital
animals but we're talking about creating
a digital environment because if you
have digital animals in a real
environment you end up having to replace
a lot of it anyway I had been through a
lot of that with Ironman mm-hmm
so the idea that we're just gonna go for
it and I had been talking actually Rob
legato about another project called
Magic Kingdom where I was trying to
think of what's the smallest footprint
you needed on a film to get at photo
real and convincing and I had met him on
the Hugo Tour and he was nice enough to
invite me over show me a lot of stuff he
had worked on on many films and other
projects and really gave me a good
education all the while in the back of
my head I'm praying I hope I get to work
with this guy he knows everything about
this stuff and just to introduce the
last piece of the puzzle sure John
Debney I've worked with since elf and I
had heard his story about having grown
grown up on the Disney lot meeting Walt
his dad had worked on Snow White and he
was a lot brat and I was hearing stories
about it as we've collaborated over the
years and I remember we worked with
Richard Sherman on a theme in Iron Man 2
for the stark Expo
and I thought that was wonderful so John
was always in the back of my head for
this knowing that he really lived and
breathed the legacy of the Disney family
and and I really wanted to go for
something quite traditional that paid
homage to to my memories growing up of
Disney in addition to bringing some
new to it okay so that's kind of how it
all came together so Rob were you and
from the very start working on previous
and stuff like that or and everything
was everything recorded and kind of
storyboard it out before you began
working on live-action or were you know
this is interesting because a lot of
this came from the storyboarding process
sort of moved over to what Rob had
worked on with avatar he showed me a
whole new way of doing this okay so he
was on pretty early on yeah I think was
on from the very beginning and first
talk about I think we had the first
meeting at Fairview about even the
process of doing the film and what would
we do and how would we do it and you
know I came from a firm belief that if
you pre-visit in a naturalistic virtual
cinematography way you will get happy
accidents you will get cinema
cinematography interpretations which are
all story points and like when you frame
something you frame it because what
story you're trying to tell with each
individual shot and you do that manually
you look through it you just take a step
back take a step to the right and all of
a sudden feels like a movie it feels
like a you've told the story with the
camera so mama firm believer in that and
you need to really kind of get the
elements in the scene up on its feet so
you can start to make these adjustments
and then photograph it and then edit it
in a normal a deterrent
so you can choose when you want to see
the close-up when you want to see the
why Sean when all those things and in
other computer-generated films they tend
to storyboard out and just produce that
three-second bursts at five-second burst
and then you just sort of string it
together and that doesn't really have
this analog cinematography background or
artist background of that kind because
stage it's all everything's all related
it's all staging is is art it's it's you
know a performance art and then
photographing in such a way to take
advantage of that and capitalize on it
to me was important and it was important
to John and John was on board with that
or we were both on board at the same
time that if we make a photorealistic
film it has to feel like a movie you
can't feel like you know a hyper real
animated thing it's got to feel like a
real thing and we went to great pains to
make sure that we shot it like a movie a
shot sometimes the light does not match
sometimes the camera angles jiggle a
little bit or do something and you just
take advantage the
or the rhythm or the energy you get from
these things and the best way of doing
it is to kind of do it live you really
need to it also involves a director it's
like I like that shot I don't like that
shot I I think if I want to tell the
story I need to be wider I think we need
to make me do a camera move here and all
of a sudden you start engaging an actor
director into the normal realm of
filmmaking as opposed to you're into
this kind of computer world and to
technical and all that stuff right so
how did you you have a child who is the
only live-action element how did you get
his performance to match in with the
environments that well that's the real
that's the real high wire act here
because we really made the movie three
times that's it so the first thing was
we said okay let's treat like an
animated movie and this is as I'm
working with Justin and now I bring on a
whole story Department as you would in
an animated film and animated films have
much better batting average than
live-action one of the reasons is they
really stress test the story and if you
just watch any of the you know
additional materials on a Pixar DVD they
put so much work into designing the
color space and the the palette the
character designs the environments and
and then they they work through the
story like sometimes eight times in show
reels before they ever commit to making
the film or ever you know turn a
computer on for rendering and so I had a
head of story a story department and we
kept as we were doing drafts and we were
giving notes we would actually have
animators do rough sketches of the whole
thing so we could watch the whole movie
and then once we signed off on that you
would normally on animated film go into
layout which means on a computer you
would stage the characters you would
begin to do simple animation set start
to set lights and camera angles but in
this that's when we did what Rob was
talking about and that's really when Rob
rolled up his sleeves because we went to
a volume we had people in motion capture
suits we designed the environments like
you would almost a video game and we
would Scout on a computer using an xbox
controller or a VR headset and we would
look in the volume and start to pick it
out as though we were filming in a real
location with an aid
with a cinematographer bill Pope and
with with Rob we had the whole crew
there and we had the kid Neel Sethi in
the motion capture suit and if it was a
bear we would have a two actors in in
motion capture suits like an old
vaudeville horse walking with the kid
and when you looked on the screen you
would see the entire environment in a
bear walking around and we did that at
DD in a volume once we finished doing
the motion capture version of the film
we would give all the dailies of all the
shots that bill or Rob would do to my
editor mark Laveau see and they would
cut it together as if it were dailies
and then once we locked in a cut there
in the meantime we're also recording the
voices and bringing the kid with Bill
Murray having Bill Murray and
Christopher Walken together everybody
together that we could to get that those
great audio tracks that we would also
cut in the editing room like that like a
radio play and also pull reference of
the facial facial expressions and eye
contact patterns with three cameras
sometimes motion capture usually just
witness cams give those to the animators
so that as we cut it together we're also
cutting together the actual actors so
that down the line we could animate it
then after we finished with the hope
we're like an avatar they would begin
rendering at that point we then began
principal photography so we would take
every shot of the kid and figure out how
far he moved where the camera is where
the lights were and that part looked
more like gravity small set if he walked
20 feet we would build 20 feet of set we
would light it have blue screen and as
we would shoot each shot we would go
behind the curtain and cut it into the
movie pull the kid and show it to him
and and by the end of photography every
kid shot had the kid in it and then we
would go into post-production and
animation as you would on a standard
film so what do you have that easy yeah
right
anybody could do it I could do it so
when he pulls up when he has certain
things in his hands were those handmade
problems anything he touched or anything
that cast a shadow on him those are the
key things but anything except like and
this is really where rob and and his
crew earned their earned their keep here
is we did things that they didn't do in
other films and we we welcomed
opportunities to have interactivity so
if the kid is saying goodbye to the wolf
and sing and run running his fingers
through her fur we put that right in
front of the camera normally you'd sort
of say could we do it this way put it
behind the wolf No through the fur and
not only that but it wasn't a showy
effect shot it was an emotional shot
with great music the rain falling good
performance from the kid Lupita Nyong'o
selling it with her voice and her
performance and having them touch heads
and those are the moments they think
make this thing that I'm most proud of
that the visual effects shots that you
don't think of as a visual effect shot
it just they just disappear so John you
had the kind of this was part of the
plan I think to incorporate some of the
Sherman Brothers songs and there and yet
it had to feel kind of intrinsic to what
was going on it wasn't a physical so
what were the choices on a on a riding
level and also in the composing level of
saying okay we're going to use a little
bit of this here and then you also took
pieces of it in your score so that
people who are familiar with it will get
it and yet at the same time it had to
work for people who didn't know the film
so can you talk about that kind of well
I'd be curious to know if if the songs
were in the script I've been an early
version and I think they were
yeah bare necessities they're a
necessity that was there was a real
inspiration point I think for the
relationship between Mowgli and blue
because it was this this idea of it was
a song that friends would sing with each
other just like two kids pushing their
bikes and they'd have a song that they
sang on the way to the baseball game or
something like that and so that was
their mantra that's how they lived and
thematically then it could it could
build into that and I think what you
guys did with I want to be like you that
was one that was really a I think
another experiment and and really
interesting it was that wanna be was was
a tougher one bear necessities I think
you it sounds like Justin you guys had
it in script for him it was always and
probably in the script wanna be like you
was something John wanted to add but he
was he was very concerned and very
rightly so he wanted it to feel organic
to the film he didn't want want to be
like you to just come out of the the
ether and then oh we're in a
song-and-dance number now and so we
worked that was one of hardest pieces in
the whole score to do and we kept we
kept tweaking it we kept adding more of
the song in before Chris Walken starts
singing so it was a process trial and
error and I think what we where we ended
up is pretty pretty cool it's organic to
what's happening in the scene and in in
the story overall but hopefully it
doesn't come out from complete
left-field and those of you that know
the song I think people that know the
song and love it are very overjoyed to
hear it and others have artists familiar
I think the first reaction might be wow
what's the song okay this is so every
step of the way John was very careful
and very concerned about music and in
these songs that are so iconic he wanted
them to be absolutely integrated
organically so Justin did you originally
I think it was John who wanted to change
car to female voice so did you have to
change any of the script at all when
that when that occurred I think that was
at the very beginning of Africa's
character was John's idea that this
should be this should be a female and
okay that created in in her character
this this motherly seductive energy that
that suddenly fit very well it was
always in in our minds that cause should
be the vehicle of exposition to sort of
talk a little bit about where Mowgli had
come from because he wanted to start the
movie
away and did not want to get into that
at the beginning which I think was a
great choice and to have this you know
Scarlett Johansson this very seductive
voice just kind of luring him in and
luring us in as an audience and kind of
circling us it was it was great it was
something that I don't think would have
felt the same
if the gender had been switched well I
wish we could talk longer but
congratulations and thank you hope to
see you back here soon
thank you all